offer me
money offer me
power I don't care so you just don't
care so want I want to say and if if if
uh the consequence of that is losing
money so be
it brothers and sister just imagine for
a second that you give £10 in donation
and that £10 is used to buy food or
bricks or whatever to help the people in
Gaza but then just imagine this amazing
de that you want to do but we turn it
into a moneymaking machine how the one
is exactly that they take your money and
the money that we are going to put in in
this W this building and every single
time the money generated from that W
that building is going to go to our
Palestinian brothers and sisters for the
next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years and
this will be a form of
true I myself will be donating for that
inshallah click the link below and
donate may Allah subhana bless and
preserve you guys I've watched two
videos and it's made me so so angry and
sometimes I don't know if I should blame
the Muslims ourselves or blame this
clown Elon scum he's not Elon Musk he's
Elon scum in my eyes here are there two
videos the first one is of him claiming
that Israel doesn't Target innocent
civilians on purpose I mean the rebuttal
is often made that uh well you know but
but you know Israel has killed
civilians you know also in Gaza but the
there is an important difference here
which is that Israel tries to avoid
killing civilians uh doing everything he
can to to avoid killing civilians of
course not when they attack the
hospitals the schools yes of course not
when they attacked civilian
infrastructure of course not it's
definitely not intentional Hamas is
sleeping underneath the basement in all
those buildings yeah right yeah and it's
unbelievable up to nearly 15,000
innocent men women children and babies
have been killed they do do not care the
blood of Muslims and Arabs is cheap it's
cheap that's what it
is difficult day uh to see the places
where people were murdered I just did a
talk with the Prime Minister and um I
think there's I mean obviously there are
three things that need to happen uh in
the Gaza situation I mean there's no
choice but
to kill those who insist on murdering
civilians there's no chice um they're
not going to change their mind so you
can clearly see he's saying those who
kill innocent civilians must be killed
and I thought to myself I'll have to
disagree with you there Elon scum
because we don't believe that just CA
Israelis the IDF the Israeli government
is killing innocent men women and
children and babies in Gaza that Hamas
should do the same we don't believe that
so I disagree with you that you're
saying that those who kill innocent
civilians should be killed
oh sorry oh I get what you're saying
you're talking about
Hamas supposedly allegedly killing
innocent civilians Israeli civilians on
purpose yes and we've said in our
religion it is clear-cut that the
killing of any civilian for that matter
is forbidden we don't care if it's a
Christian Muslim whoever is for that
matter it's forbidden but what you're
doing here is the following you are
seeing that Hamas is killing innocent
civilians apparently yes on purpose yes
which there has to be evidence brought
forth of course there has been killing
civilians but is it on purpose directly
there's many speculations the own uh
newspapers harits and IDE of soldiers
have them self claimed they were
attacking their own civilians and they
don't even have a protocol in place
which is called Hannibal protocol or
something along that lines where they
attack their own civilians yes they
attack their own soldiers yes so do you
see that as Muslims we will condemn what
you're seeing by claiming if the context
was that Israel killing innocent men
women children the same Hamas should do
to them it's forbidden in our religion
but we know you're not talking about
Israel you're talking about Hamas you're
talking about that if they do that
therefore they are Justified Israel is
Justified and you as a utilitarian which
you are which is a um a false uh a a
ideology yes and you're saying that it
is Justified Israel is justified by
killing them as long as you know for
every like Muhammed said with the Unholy
Shi the clown yes who's obsessed with
him because he got destroyed the point
is what for the ratio is one for every
1001 yes so basically if we can kill one
Hamas and at the same time kill 100
innocent Palestinians it is Justified
you're a scum your name is Elon scum
from that one you are a scum and I'm
putting a big X on you yes okay that's
what you you an X I'm putting a big X on
your face you scum you are justifying
you are talking about the horrific
atrocities that you may have seen the
propaganda that they showed you of a a
cut yes with bullets around it I I I
find it so bizarre why are there Hamas
bullets that unfired on the on the cour
I don't understand I find it so bizarre
to me I it's very very odd and the point
is the following guys we should condemn
anyone that's K innocent for that matter
but the fact that Elon Musk specific ly
chooses to defend Israel yes this
government this genocidal war criminals
yes and the wo turns a blind eye it
shows you and I'm going to end on this
verse in the Quran Allah subhana says
inah
Allah says in the Quran and this day is
going to come so today those who believe
will laugh at the the
disbelievers while sitting and reclining
on couches and they will be seeing
whether the disbelievers have been paid
back for for what they used to do
brothers and sisters do not seek Justice
Just in this life cuz the Justice in the
hereafter is much greater Allah is
telling us that the Believers who'll be
successful inshallah will be on these
reclining sufers because they were
oppressed and they will be looking at
these evil evil the enemies disbelievers
are not General specific disbelievers
yes who committed these atrocities we
will see with our own eyes them being
dragged to the fire and those who are
complacent to what these governments are
doing you are a part of it and you will
go down in history as a flipping scum
Elon scum that's what you are and may
Allah subhana wa tala deal with deal
with you because you are either it's the
money or it's some other issues that I
have been shown to you or you've been
threatened with that you've changed your
tune but one thing that is clear he does
not give a single damn they don't care
about you they do not care as Muslims if
we start to rely more on Allah than
individuals or this person got this
platform and anytime we get happy yes it
is normal we can mention this person is
doing that but deep down our Reliance
should be on Allah subhana you're a scum
Elon scum that's what you are till next
time hope you guys have learned a lesson
that you put your trust in Allah and not
Elon scum or anyone for that matter
goodbye